aïe
je lis des cinq sens inverse dans le
derrière la façade derrière joly est
tiré
alors qu'est ce qu'on dirait
un père noël avec son fusil dans le dos
en cherchant bien
d'ailleurs quand on doit décider on
comprend que d'imaginer le choix c'est
pas moi qui fais les tâches et monty un
attentat mais c'est bien c'est bien un
requin raie un peu tu vois tu avais dit
qu'on faisait des passes à jeudi le
passage de la de la lumière dans les 3
ans du tout rendu trop lent et où aussi
bien
et nous sommes c'est que ça fasse opérer
un petit peu plus le voilà voilà n'a pas
perdu au change
c'est vraiment un m'as forcée des
cultures toi
hier le maire de matha sont des cultures
de luxe ce qui va avoir le plus de
contrats voilà par contre on va
descendre pour rappeler le soleil soit
tout à l'heure alors
propulsé comment se porte ce que tu
défaire aux plantations
parce qu'ils ont un terrain qu'ils ont
achetés
la tournée à temps on va tourner autour
de hockey les parties de tourner parce
j'y vois là ces biotopes ça parce que
jodar
guy ranson face b
pasqua
alors je n'osais pas ouais enfin quoique
j'ai fait un peu mou système blanc ouais
mais tous étaient pas à bouger enfants
par rapport à ce qu'on a fait à l'heure
c'est sûr que là c'est toi regarde pas
ce genre de toutes ses papattes à québec
il pâtit et à la grâce à l'utpas plongé
un peu c'était pas mal de bourgi sur des
trains sur 10 pour une fois plus axé là
on est pro sen arrive en pin balma sur
l'accès aux quais été par le passé la
ligne
alors les accès complètement vu qu'on a
passé la ligne en descente à deux matchs
du godard aurait dû qu'aux fins parti
tory et du groupe à deux points de
compétence c'est parti les enfants
on oublie pas qu on est en jeu c'est
parler tout le temps très très lent donc
on arrive d'être là face
rien à en baisser bien l'enfer un public
si on n'en fait jamais on est vachement
trou l'ange tous viennent me l'a dit on
a des problèmes de lenteur non tant pour
toujours dans les cinquante images
yann m'a dit ah ouais je lui dois un
coup de raquette un champ bien que
derrière tu es très beau par quentin lui
quant aux preuves en quelques hommes en
descendent jusqu'au 20 décembre après la
ligne ou pas tout de suite se fasse au
four à descendre facilement celui là que
ligne tant mieux si c'est aux efforts de
l'est b-cargo d'after the line
godard à madrid si on va sur le vert et
le jaune jusqu'à l'alsace il doit soit
finie sur l'arbre peu dans les arbres
voilà joli salon auquel s'étaient bien
ou pas bien on voit là ok
je suis à gauche
le voir le paquet voit le bâtiment bien
ça vachement bien
thor est il arrivé au bout vachement
bien vachement bien
alors ayons qui va râler sur lui travers
un rayon j'ai plaisir à le faire
à tours font rien du tout non non je
suis bien mais sa jeune et brillant je
sais pas yacé en essayent quoi on a une
brillance le bonheur en sort vers
locales devant une bruyante seulement
celui de pierre rester-là la brillance
et les verts comme le soleil et
comprendre le lien soleil
j'ai passé tant contre
alors il a
non mais nettement par rapport à soi un
appel à leur talent était vraiment dans
ce double cd musique rock et on laisse
tomber alors [ __ ] bien planqué vous
fait un planqué voilà c'est pas sûr
pourtant pas beau ça alors la paix à
l'arrivée on large
c'est encore un descendant les champs
maintenant ça fait le ski l'antenne
voilà
allez
et pénales
lutterbach le cabinet
on en sourit pierre arial sonatrach est
la seconde de la pole au mans
drôle
les boutons wright
ok
voilà toit par gearbox